i'm trevor phillips this is common
ground
in a world of conflict and division all
too many believe that if you're not with
us you must be against us
but does every problem have to be solved
by the loudest voices or the biggest
armies
tonight
through the public order bill that i
will be bringing forward we will see new
criminal offences for those disruptive
protesters that really bring our country
to a grinding halt
in the queen's speech the government
pledges to curb disruptive protests even
if they're non-violent
ministers say that people who block the
highways and glue themselves to gates
aren't heroes they're extremist
nuisances who stop law-abiding folk
getting to work
activists like those who protest under
the banner of extinction rebellion
[ __ ] that the fate of humanity is at
stake and that like the civil rights or
anti-apartheid movements their cause
transcends any degree of day-to-day
inconvenience
the environmental movement itself is
split
some activists fear that the tactics of
groups like insulate britain or just
stop oil are turning off the public
provoking a political backlash and
setting back half a century of progress
but many eco warriors insist that change
never comes without conflict and their
fight for climate justice even if it
lands them in jail will see them on the
right side of history
our choice
are climate protesters justified in
disrupting society
or are they killing their own cause
in the next 60 minutes two passionate
believers come head to head in the
search for common ground
[Music]
with me tonight claire farrell the
co-founder of extinction rebellion
anxion lights founder of the climate
campaign group emergency reactor let's
start preparing the ground find out a
bit more about our two guests and what
they believe and if i can start with you
zion
what's your case against the methods
being deployed by extinction rebellion
and similar groups
i'm not against using civil disobedience
in general i think it absolutely has a
place and that extinct rebellion has
used it very well particularly in moving
the needle on where the discussions are
around climate change i was talking
about climate change for many years
before they came on the scene and that's
why i was happy to get involved because
they really shifted that and that's
amazing and they've done a brilliant job
but i think now that
people turning against these protests is
worrisome i find the policing bill
worrisome i don't think that
you know our rights should be eroded i
think that
the right to protest is a cornerstone of
british democracy
and although i'm not putting that
specifically on these groups because i
think that they have a really just cause
there was a yougov poll last month that
showed that 65 of britain support the
policing bill measures and that really
worries me and i think actually we need
to have tactics that bring ordinary
working people along with these
arguments so that they don't just turn
against climate action because their day
has been disrupted you yourself were
one of the spokespeople a leader in
extinction rebellion and what made you
fall out of love
i was a spokesperson and i helped in the
media team to find a newspaper and the
reason for that was because i believe we
should try to reach different people and
have conversations with people who
aren't traditionally interested in
environmental issues
the reason i shifted my perspective was
because i felt that certain things were
turning people off and i think the
turning point for me came around the
cunning town actions um which became a
little bit violent and again you know
really disrupted this is where people
got on top of a train at the canning
town station in london yeah and i was
very vocal about that in the groups and
they were you know there was a split
there where some people disagreed and
some people said it's really necessary
but i just think that if it's turning
away ordinary people these are you know
people who are struggling to put food on
the table struggling with their energy
bills i've been in this environmental
movement for about 20 years and i think
we've we've not appealed to those groups
for a long time and we really have to
change that we have to get everyone on
board with climate action okay
claire farrell
i don't think there's any question that
some of the tactics involve disruption
and law breaking what is the case for
that well as you've already pointed out
there's this enormous uh
i would say noble and long tradition of
non-violence and civil disobedience
causing uh rapid and unjust change so
people fighting for justice have used
this many many times these kinds of
tactics
um
you know you would think that
the sort of projected collapse of
civilization which is what is going to
happen on the course that we're on right
now
uh
would be a serious enough cause
for people to be able to you know you
unite against leaders who are
intentionally apparently
leading them
off a cliff and the policing bill and
the measures that are being brought in
are uh
as i think david lammy spoke very well
in parliament last year
really because the government are either
too stupid or too cowardly to respond
appropriately to the crisis that they
are being asked to deal with as leaders
and so the dereliction of leadership
which has been pointed out by antonio
gutierrez uh you know in his recent
speech after the last ipcc report came
out you know the subtext of the message
that he said was basically ordinary
people of the world it's over to you all
right look um we're going to unpack some
of that but let me just um ask in a way
the same question that i've asked you on
why does this matter to you personally
thomas you put yourself in a position
to
be arrested in fact you have been
arrested i think
more more than once
why do you personally feel so passionate
about this
um
i don't really understand why everyone
doesn't i i can't morally i can't exist
in a world which is going to collapse
around my nephews my god daughter and
all the young people in the world i
can't sit by whilst people in pakistan
and india are dying because of the heat
whilst there's enormous flooding taking
place that's taking hundreds and
thousands of lives all over the world
we're already in a state of breakdown
it's not like we're raising an alarm
it's like we're here saying guys it's
actually already too late so the least
we could do is slam the brakes on and
try to make it less worse but that's the
that's the reality of the situation
we're in so it's not really for me a
question of why do i care so much it's
more extraordinary to me why isn't
everybody out on the on the streets with
us when it's so clear that people in
leadership in politics and business are
intentionally continuing to make this
worse not better
both of you clearly agree that this is
if
i think you would both say this is
probably the number one issue of our
time right um
if it is such a big issue is it not big
enough
uh that it merits disregard
both for
the existing law and popular opinion i
mean that's a that's the truth of all
ages that some people think that some
things are so important
that you have to break through the
framework of law and custom
of the time
to
prosecute that particular course well
let me pick up the question a little bit
the suffragettes are often cited as you
know a prime example of they use civil
disobedience they achieved their aims
absolutely brilliant fantastic it took
them over 100 years we don't have
that time right now we don't have that
time and people in execution would agree
we don't have that time and my concern
is that 15 years ago i was arrested
twice for climate action uh once
protesting a coal-fired power station
once protesting tar sands so i've been
doing this for a long time and i'm kind
of saying i don't think that it's
working in the way that we want it to
work it has worked uh to a degree and
that it really you know the april
rebellion i got involved in the
beginning that brought a lot of people
on side it um
you know it felt like a really pivotal
moment people were suddenly very
concerned it was all of the media that
was all thanks to extinct rebellion and
their work and it was very successful
but then the tide has shifted you know
and actually one one thing that happened
is that 75 percent of britons then in
that kind of year of acceptable existing
they became very concerned about climate
change in the environment that was new
and that has stayed consistent even
through the pandemic so that work has
been done but now we need to lead people
to solutions is why i started a group to
fight for solutions because i fear that
that's being lost in just pushing the
same message again and again and again
which is
spreading fear we're going to go through
all of that bit by bit just very quickly
uh to you claire um
you accept that there's a scientific
basis
for the arguments around climate change
do you would accept what the ipc or c or
the world metropol metrolog
meteorological organizations say you
accept the science that there's science
here
well yeah i mean that's one of the main
drivers for a lot of people in in taking
action but i would say that what's
really important when you're thinking
about the science as a lens and what
gets called the science is that we've i
believe we've been using the wrong
intellectual framework to look at this
problem because it's not purely a
problem of science and it's not even
purely a problem of politics but it is a
problem which involves risk and no risk
analyst would ever look at the collapse
of your home and say it's okay to give
you a 50 50 chance you wouldn't build a
bridge if there was more than a tiny
minute percentage chance of any harm
coming to somebody who goes onto that
bridge we don't build those things but
for some reason because the scientific
discipline has been the only lens that
we've used to look at climate people
have said well there's a 20 chance that
we will make 1.5 or there's actually
right now there's a zero percent chance
we're going to make 1.5 by the way but
you know using a risk analysis lens
would be a much more useful intellectual
framework to take and of course then
that throws into stark relief the
political problem which is that we can
see quite clearly in this country our
politicians are incapable of looking at
the world for a risk lens and making
smart decisions you know
okay well that's very interesting i want
to come back to that that that actually
even small risks are worth
trying to avoid um let's just start to
unpack each of your cases if i may start
with with you zeon um
i guess the the main question that might
be
put it to your position it's very simple
that uh the sort of reformism that the
persuasion the case for persuasion that
you're making that we've got to take the
public with us and all of that um
just isn't working cop 26
some people i would say it was all right
but nobody thought it was a stupendous
success
today the world meteorological
organization says that we are almost
certain to see a one and a half percent
rise
uh in
um world temperature world surface
temperature
over the pre-industrial levels in the
next five years and i'm going to read
what the ipc's say going to happen is
going to happen
once in a century floods happening every
year
major cities in south asia and middle
east experiencing lethal heat for at
least 200 days a year total loss of
coral reefs irreversible acceleration in
sea level rises as the ice caps melt so
we might
uh you know we might all take take
everybody along with us we might not do
things in a democratic way but we're all
going to drown together in a nice
democratic way i mean i've been talking
about this for you know you don't have
to convince me i completely agree what
i'm saying is that the tactics that i
was involved in 15 years ago are still
being used today and at some point we
have to go do we need to reassess this
because it isn't working it's we worked
in that it's created a shift and people
are now talking about it but is it
working in the action we need to see
this change that we need to see i don't
believe that it is and that's where i
think um you know we need to look at
what what we're actually what messaging
we're pushing and how effective that is
for example scaring a lot of people
about the issue okay fine we've kind of
done that children are very worried
there's high degrees of
equal anxiety among kids but is that
helping them to build the resilience
that they need to live in this world
right this is the world that they're
going to have to adapt to shouldn't we
be talking about solutions and
mitigation and all of the science and
all of the things that's still at our
disposal yes it is too late for some
things but but it's not too late to you
know we shouldn't completely give up i
mean i think we're in agreement about
that but then we need to look at what
solutions are and push for those to be
implemented in somewhere like here where
we live in a democracy yes i have plenty
of issues with this government but we do
live in a democracy where we can push
for the solution to what i see is that
there's not a lot of that happening
there's just not a lot of that happening
we just keep pushing the same messaging
be afraid about climate change and then
we say why aren't people more worried
about it people are worried about
putting food on the table people are
worried about getting their kids to
school on time because you blocked a
road yeah yes we can't bring everybody
on board but what i'm saying is i've
watched for 15 years as those people
have not been brought on board and now
65 of them are saying yeah we support
these policing bills that's worrying to
me that should be worrying to all of us
clear your tactics are leaving the
majority of people behind
well i just i don't agree and you know
to go back to canning town for example
you know i did a lot of interviews that
day very few people unsurprisingly
wanted to be the face of exile that day
and go on the news
and um
you know what i tried to draw people's
attention to was that this is just one
action
which unfortunately didn't go as well as
a planned i think there were mistakes
made about choosing that station
but
there was disastrous
relations well
maybe but it also spread much further
than any other action we've ever done
right so that's another question it was
on the front page in other countries the
news here doesn't follow anything unless
it's dramatic novel you know we have to
do extraordinary amount of work to
pander to a media which has also
performed an abject dereliction of duty
in terms of informing the public about
the crisis and the danger that they're
actually really in um but just to speak
about that action people don't know that
many other actions where people climbed
on trains glued themselves to trains
have been through the court system
they've been in front of a jury in a
crown court and they've been acquitted
because the jury don't think that
campaigning to try and stop the
breakdown of civilized life is
disproportionate to delaying a train for
about 70 minutes so it was unfortunate
that those people had that experience on
that train platform they were found
guilty and they were
sentenced to some punishment but every
other person who did exactly the same
thing has been acquitted in a court now
that goes along with other cases of ours
which are going through the court system
where they're also being acquitted by
juries and so for me that shows that
this policing bill and the approach of
this government is entirely out of step
with what the public's actual reaction
is when they're faced with the the
question of justice
movement you know there's an interesting
point there isn't there that actually as
you say you you said a couple of times
you've been making this case for 15
years um
had it not been for some of what people
would describe as more extreme actions
of some activist
uh
nobody would have noticed but i'm not
disagreeing with that and i was you know
involved in some of these actions myself
but but i have also given figures from a
yougov poll that was from last month i
urge people to look it up that found
that 65 of the british public support
the bill that worries me it worries me
that we not only have a policing bill
but an elections bill and a nationality
in borders bill that is stripping away
the rights of british people and they
don't even realize this has never
happened before in my lifetime this is
very worrying why is that much control
being exerted over our citizens but
stopping clear climbing on a train isn't
going to change uh pretty patel's mind
about this is it claire can climb
wherever she likes that's not my concern
my concern is that if you're not taking
ordinary working people along with you
then look it's become very polished
let's just strip it back for a second
it's almost as if if you don't sit in a
road now you don't care about climate
change that's my concern there has to be
space for everybody in this movement not
everybody has a house where they can
they own it and they put solar panels on
it and they can have an ev and heat
pumps they are struggling to put food on
the table and you see it play out in
things like canning town and you see it
play out yes the judge and the jewelry
who don't have to worry about those
things are very supportive but if you
look at just what ordinary people are
saying or what the polls are saying this
a lot of ordinary people are just
getting very angry about it and it
worries me because i think that could
that could set us back quite a long way
and we don't have time for that we need
to get lots of people on board we need
to talk about for example we can talk
about solutions like you know i think
we all come onto solutions but i just
want to be clear about tactics are you
saying that xr should just stop all this
gluing and handcuffing and timing
or not no i'm not saying that at all oh
you think it's okay for them to break
the law i i
think that stripping away our right to
protest is chilling and should not
happen it is part of our history is part
of british legacy
hardly ever we hardly ever have positive
change without these movements
absolutely
people should have the right to protest
at the same time these people are very
aware that they might go to jail so even
actually stricter laws are not going to
deter them anyway so the people who are
making these laws don't understand the
reasons which are driven by integrity
and passion and fear about the planet
that those are real reasons and they're
not going to go away just because you
locked them up so it's completely wrong
anyway all i'm saying is that if you
look at the history of how long we're
doing this in the environmental movement
it is not making enough shifts it's not
bringing enough people along and i've
heard this said by people
in accenture villain to me we don't need
to bring everyone along xeon and i
that's where i disagree i disagree there
are waves of protesting that aren't just
disrupting people look at things like in
france where they blocked the um they um
the tube station
you know and people could go they could
travel for free this is supporting
public transport this is getting people
on board that's very clever tactics it's
not it's not sit in a road or you don't
care there are lots of different ways of
campaigning and i just think it's worth
exploring those different ways of
campaigning and trying to choose the
things that are
before we talk about the menu campaign i
just want to get one thing uh clear with
you claire you've referred a couple of
times to
the proposals that the government's
making on public order bill
if those
changes are brought in and go through
parliament
will that stop you
uh taking the sort of action that you
and your colleagues have taken in the
past
which would would involve you know
gluing yourself to bits of the
infrastructure and so on well
i think there's an enormous power in our
movement which is not going to be
deterred by this stuff because as you
say the movement was set up to say we
will peacefully break the law so writing
new laws to stop it is kind of funny
right um but at the same time your
message
knock yourself out pass your lawn it's
not going to make any difference the
problem with this is that you know it's
also
impacting a lot of people in very
different ways so you can look at the
gypsy roman traveler communities who've
just had their way of life made illegal
basically and at the same time you know
the destruction of people's rights to
protest at the same time threatening to
deport people just for having dual
nationality to a country perhaps so
they've never even been in their life
you know this it's it's an extraordinary
assault on democracy which has taken
place in the mother of all democracies
where they're basically strangling it in
front of everyone's eyes and i would say
just on zion's point that like the
public aren't uh are in favor of this
policing bill stuff i think the public
are being enormously uh polarized and
guided by a disgraceful media campaign
to smear activists to enrage people if
you saw the tv show yesterday where the
mum who drove into the protesters with
her suv meets uh tracy mannigan from
insulate britain and they have a really
beautiful conversation on a morning tv
show just the other day because they are
actually in agreement about everything
so the media whips that violence up
against protesters and that is very
unsafe people try to do that work you
know okay well gov nobody from the
government is here to um
uh explain their position we'll take a a
break now because we've been hearing
quite a lot of what uh
uh zeon thinks and i want to turn in a
moment to uh
uh examine a bit more closely what
you've been saying claire we'll be back
in a few moments
[Music]
[Music]
yes
[Music]
we've got post brexit challenges we've
got post coded challenges we've got
customers that have been told to stay at
home for the last two years who need to
get back into the habit of coming out
and enjoying our world-class live music
scene and then of course we're running
slap bang into a cost of living crisis
which is putting huge pressure on
disposable income
i'd say it's threefold first of all you
know we the government did a very
effective job of telling people to stay
at home for two years let's tell people
to get out and enjoy everything we have
you know the stones might be the most
high profile example of the the strange
market we have at the moment for tickets
but the vast majority of gigs and
festivals are independently owned the
small businesses and we want people to
get out there and enjoy them
then secondly you know
we believe there should be a cultural
rate for that on ticket sales that would
bring us in line with many other
countries around the world we've just
had that go back up to 20
we think it should be more around about
the five percent mark
and then really fundamentally it's about
you know can we be putting money back
into household budgets to spare to go
out to gigs because as i said they that
money goes to independent venues which
then goes right back into the local
economy and people buying tickets for
gigs also support local hairdressers
local boutiques
right the way through to the taxi at the
end of the night
[Music]
organized
[Music]
[Music]
the inspiration behind our product came
from
understanding how big of a problem
livestock meat and emissions were
i'm ivan bonio i'm a sailor
i spent
half time of my life on the on the sea
we have a factory who can convert this
plastic to energy
and so after at the end we can minimize
the footprint carbon of the board
this is common ground i'm joined by
claire farrell the co-founder of
extinction rebellion and zeon lights
founder of the climate campaign group
emergency reactor
we're talking about whether climate
protesters have got it wrong
um
claire farrell
we've been talking about the issue of
public support
is there a danger that you are
overstating
the case and alienating possible
supporters for example um
do you really believe that we are
experiencing i'm quoting here from
the xr website uh your biography
corporate state planned mass murder do
you really believe that
yes
i do
because the people in power know very
well the situation they understand
what's taking place they understand what
needs to be done about it and for
example take this you know government
leading the cop process in glasgow our
leaders are in tears saying that they
are concerned they've failed humanity
that the children all around the world
are going to suffer that people are
already suffering these impacts and
within a matter of months they're
licensing for new oil and gas out of the
north sea when they know that we need to
stop taking fossil fuels out of the
ground i mean they may be making
mistakes but that is not a mistake
that's not a mistake but it's not a
mistake that is an intentional decision
to make something that is irreversible
and catastrophic worse and more
guaranteed and to do so via policy
decisions which only a few months
previous you wouldn't have dared to say
because you were crying on the national
media about your fear for the future in
light of climate change the problem here
is that there's no coherence people
can't hold the reality it's like a hyper
object the climate right it's
complicated it's scary it's difficult to
tackle but on some fronts we know
precisely what needs to be done and we
know the people who've caused it and we
know the people who've lied to the
public and we know the campaigns that
they've done in the fossil fuel sector
to mislead the media the public and the
politicians they did it for decades
they've done it for well over a
generation and we've lost that time and
we can never get it back and the people
who are in power today need to grow up
and accept their responsibility and the
context that they are in because history
will judge them for what they do now and
opening new oil and gas right now as the
president of the cop process globally is
one of the most offensive and disgusting
acts that this government could ever
have done and you know the public should
be rightly outraged and they're
struggling in a crisis for the cost of
living they're struggling with an energy
crisis people are worried about the war
in ukraine yes these things are very
important but this is this looming
enormous prospect of the breakdown of
our biosphere which people have to take
seriously and if they refuse to yes i do
think it's mass murder zeon um
it's quite a charge and i suppose it
follows it
you're
let's put it this way soft it's off the
approach is letting mass murderers off
the hook i mean i campaign for clean
energy so i completely agree that we
should keep fossil fuels in the ground
but i've been saying that for a long
time and it hasn't changed anything and
gluing myself into stuff hasn't changed
anything so now i work with the
emergency reactor you know trying to
educate the public trying to talk to
people about clean energy trying to
encourage politicians to clean energy by
the way you mean nuclear and renewables
but i find most people already support
renewables so nuclear energy is the
difficult thing which i've chosen to
tackle and actually these environmental
groups need to make up their mind
because they say follow the science but
they reject nuclear energy when i came
out supporting nuclear energy which is
quite a difficult thing to do as a
long-term environmentalist i was heavily
attacked including by leading
spokespeople in extinct rebellion if you
say follow the science follow what the
ipcc says which is that we need
renewables and nuclear to decarbonize as
simple as that and secondly you can't
have it all we have to get our energy
from somewhere so absolutely let's get
rid of fossil fuels but then fight for
the solutions as well
i'm going to come back to you claire on
that specific point but
i you didn't really answer
my point question about
the phrase that claire used is it mass
media is that what you're asking me i
wouldn't use that phrase people are
dying though and people will continue
tonight but i mean two billion people
living poverty people already are dying
it's an apocalyptic world in many ways
already are we making it worse
absolutely yes there are heat waves in
india right now that are killing people
and it's barely on the news i would like
to see these issues discussed more i
worry that when there's a protest and it
gets attention it becomes all about the
protest and not about what's actually
happening in the world i don't know how
we deal with that that's a media issue
and i find campaigning with my group
because we don't do these kind of uh
strong actions where we're blocking
roads and things it's very hard to get
anyone to listen and talk about things
and actually that's where i'd say use
those platforms to talk about solutions
because people aren't aware of what they
are um claire are you one of the exile
leaders who would criticize zeon for
uh promoting what she describes as clean
energy part of which would be nuclear
reactors
i've not really got a
strong opinion about nuclear on the
basis that i haven't done the depth of
research that i would like to do to be
able to say here's what i think this is
what i'm fighting for my understanding
from other people who i know who are
very passionate about it is that it's
too late because it takes a long time to
build them we need to decarbonize much
more quickly than that there are many
arguments if you think that you face the
collapse of civilization that nuclear
reactors can pose a future risk those
kinds of things those are the
conversations i hear but i'm not here to
say yes or no to nuclear or yes or no to
different forms of energy as you
probably know trevor we have a demand in
exile for participative politics so we
think people should be able to come be
included in the democratic process to
decide the way forwards and so you would
you know gather the evidence
and you said examine that you said no
you're not here to say yes or no energy
but did you not just make a huge case
for leaving oil and gas behind
yeah but i think then you have to have a
participatory process to decide how you
deal with the situation from there but
how is that following the science if the
reports are already out showing how we
need to decarbonize
how how is that how is that following
the science you said earlier that's what
we should be doing right
i don't know if you're asking people to
just follow your decisions questions
well i think what zion's saying is
you've got a clear view about uh fossil
fuels oil and gas how come you don't
have a similar view about the other
possibilities uh that might help to
stave off the crisis that you've talked
about
well because we want people to be able
to be included in a process where they
decide we don't want to be a movement
that goes around telling people what
should happen we want people to be able
to be brought together into a political
environment where they sit around tables
together and deliberate in a grown-up
way rather than the combative politics
of westminster with like posh people
arguing over an old box you know we want
real people to sit around tables and
have real grown-up conversations about
what needs to happen and yes it's going
to be complicated to work out the future
of energy policy so i'm not here to say
that i know the answers to that because
i think it's extremely complex but what
we have been told in no uncertain terms
is that there should be no new oil and
gas and that's not just from campaigners
like us it's from the international
energy agency which is hardly like a
bastion of radicalism in the world is it
you know and they said last year no new
licenses from 2021
and the international energy engine
agency also says we need renewables and
euclid to decarbonize as does the inter
governmental panel on climate change and
the united nations report so all of that
is really important and the fact that
you know you're sitting there saying you
didn't know this that's what i'm trying
to say is if you're not telling people
what the solutions are and bringing them
along with you you're just saying stop
doing this stop doing that and that's
very difficult for people to accept i
know it shouldn't be i know they should
be aware and passionate about the issues
like you are but that message isn't
getting through it's just not getting
through okay coming up we've been
hearing what both of our guests think
about each other's case um we're going
to start looking
in earnest for some common ground back
in a moment
[Music]
welcome back this is common ground i'm
joined by claire farrell the co-founder
of extinction rebellion anxion lights
founder of the climate campaign group
emergency reactor we're talking about
whether climate protesters have got it
wrong and we found out some of what our
guests think and why now um let's see if
we can
find some common ground or at least a
common understanding between
our two guests claire how do you respond
to the accusation that xr is itself
a bit of an exclusive movement
well first
first of all you know we've had a lot of
accusations of this nature uh thrown at
the movement which i think
you know firstly for people to describe
it as white and middle class routinely
erases the
taking part of people of color of people
from different class backgrounds or
people with different abilities people
from uh what you would term you know
minority groups or marginalized groups
in society there are a lot of people who
uh fit that definition in our movement
and i think that they're overlooked and
then raised by these
kind of things sometimes when they're
slung at us which i think is deeply
unfair and deeply unhelpful frankly um
there's always massive amount of work to
do of course to try and broaden the
movement to try and reach more people
but having a lot of people organizing
around their um
their own kind of
work
identity in a way we've had a lot of
people coming out because they're
scientists because they're teachers
because they're doctors
because they're lawyers because they are
students because they are people of
color because they are young people
because they are grandparents because
you know the list goes on right in terms
of like community groups that find
themselves working together people of
multiple faith groups this kind of thing
so you know it's actually a very broad
movement i would invite anyone who
thinks that it's an exclusive space
which only has one type of person in it
to come and to meet some people from
extinction rebellion and realize
hopefully that it is not and also that
there's a really diverse array of
activities it's not just people gluing
themselves to things there's lots of
family events there's lots of outreach
there's lots of different stuff that
happens under the banner of xr you know
xeon do you accept that
um i didn't make that argument that you
made um it has some diversity in there i
think there are some issues especially
with the focus on arrest as a form of
protest i think that turns a lot of
people off i understand that the idea is
to
you know normalize that and to get more
people involved so that they are willing
to risk arrest and fill the jails i
understand all of that i just think it's
quite polarizing it doesn't it's not
going to appeal to a lot of people i
know i know that that's a significant
disagreement that i have with the group
that i also had when i was in the group
um but what i would say is that i just
don't think the polarization is very
helpful and actually claire brought this
up earlier where she said look when this
lady in the 4x4 actually spoke to the
person they got along and they they had
things in common but when one person was
blocking the road and the other one was
trying to get her kid to school on time
that was very polarizing we all saw how
that played out and it was very negative
all i'm saying is is there a way to
communicate and to still protest and
push the envelope but not in such a
polarizing way because that is then what
people see and often what they end up
taking away which actually can just be
really detrimental to the cause which we
all care about which is effective
climate action
well claire what what's your response to
that that actually
we don't need it we don't need these
heist hydra dramatic uh
exhibitions and these uh protests which
inconvenience people that there may be
easier ways to persuade people
well i mean we built an extremely
successful global movement off the back
of these kinds of tactics and precisely
partly for the reason that when you
cause disruption when you make a big
noise when you get a lot of press when
people are paying attention to what
you're saying they learn about the thing
that you're saying and so there's lots
of people in our movement who joined
precisely because they came across a
road blockage because they saw it on the
news because it was disruptive because
it was interesting because there was
drama because it started a big
conversation and so this situation as i
said is not getting better it's actively
getting worse and the policies that are
being written are actively making it
worse so when you are living in a
context that your uh
political system and your political
reality is
cementing the guarantee of the breakdown
of our food systems of the uh breakdown
of biodiversity to a scale which we'll
really struggle to recover from from you
know extreme weather events that are
going to get more and more often like
the stats that you read out earlier you
know there's going to be a devastating
amount of loss of life in the future and
it's already happening now today all
over the world so you know
yes does it deserve a response which
brings the drama into people's minds
about what this really means yes i think
it really does and of course we're not
the only game in town so zeon's free to
do her campaigning the way she wants to
do it other people can do campaigning
the way they want to do it it's not like
we're the only people that do anything
about climate it's just that we do our
thing and we recognize our space as part
of a you know we're part of an ecology
of like an entire climate movement and
we just we just do a thing that we do
other people set up to do things in a
different way and i think everyone has
to work together to push in the same
direction to build the strength because
it's true like everyone won't do the
things that i do or the things that
other people in exile do but that
doesn't make them unhelpful okay
can i clarify because of the way you
asked the question i wasn't saying
these protests shouldn't happen i'm
simply questioning who they're targeting
who they're disrupting and what the
tactics are and i think those could be
shifted to something like what we said
earlier about the zhiyun there are ways
of doing things that are still
disruptive but they bring people on
board as well it's still civil
disobedience i'm not saying that we
should just give all that up and i think
that that should not be made illegal
absolutely not but
there comes a point where you have to
think all right maybe yeah the media has
fed it as well and people are turning
against this movement but then we have
to think how do we get those people back
because these changes will not be
enacted unless we bring those people
with us so um you're both on the same
place i think on the public order uh
bill has proposed as if i understand it
correctly zeon you you would be against
what is absolutely being proposed so one
piece of common ground uh
let's be clear let's be clear nobody
from the government is here to uh defend
them but um
everybody here
not me obviously i'm i'm nobody the two
of you are basically against what the
government has in mind now that's the
easy bit um you both also seem to think
that there is
uh there can be a movement which has
all sorts in it but let's let's delve on
to that into that a little bit more
deeply
are you saying zion that it doesn't
matter to you
that
uh some of the actions not necessarily
clear herself but some of the people on
that wing of the movement
which
do alienate some people
that
as far as you're concerned though you
wouldn't do it yourself it's it's just
part part of what has to happen and you
would tolerate that
not that you're against it it's just one
of the things that happened but you'd
like you'd like us to the media for
example to focus on other things
well this is a thing though i understand
it's one movement i understand that it's
doing a very specific thing but it then
sucks up all the air all the year goes
over there i'm doing events as well but
because they are not hugely disruptive
or you know
mass kind of campaigns to i don't know
people shouting at us in roads we're not
getting the platform to talk about the
science and solutions and they should be
different voices i'm not necessarily
putting that on exclusive rebellion that
is a media issue that is what they're
likely to cover but it is sucking the
air out of other parts here's a point
claire that actually
in principle what you do might not be
wrong but in reality what you're doing
is you're essentially
sucking the oxygen out of the uh out of
zeon's wing of the movement and not
allowing anybody to listen to her
well i mean i just don't think that's
true you know what zeon's just said is
is basically that people don't pay
attention to her campaign because she
doesn't do anything disruptive that's
that's what we're here to talk about
does disruption work yes we're getting
more attention is she struggling for
attention yes do something disruptive
then do you know what i mean like that
that's that seems to me the answer's
there like it's it's but i have what
works to raise the profile of an issue
but i've done the disrupt what but the
reason i stopped doing the disruptive
things is because it wasn't bringing
people along so i'm trying to do the
things that bring people along i feel
like there could be some meshing here of
what we're both trying to achieve where
we go well you know we have different
approaches like you said we need to work
together we're not actually you're kind
of going like we do our thing and you do
your thing that is not going to succeed
and i knew that 15 years ago and i still
know that now it's not going to succeed
we have to get people on board we have
to get politicians on board i know you
hate them but we have to get them on
board and we are not appealing to them
we are not appealing to groups that are
outside of our little pocket where we
really believe these things we
understand these things and we can't
just keep saying why don't they
understand over there that's our job
right to communicate that i do a lot of
communication and risk communication it
doesn't really get much press coverage
that's fine it doesn't have to but then
it's not getting the reach that you get
when you climb on a train and that is
very polarizing and it does turn some
people off and it does then become about
was the action okay wasn't it okay and
now it's going to be banned and all of
that where actually people are dying
right now through heat waves driven by
climate change no one's talking about it
claire
zeon's perhaps being um polite about
this but um i suspect that some people
who think like her would say the reason
we're getting this police bill that you
all hate is because you guys do such
unreasonable things that people who
would otherwise support your cause
want to stop you
blocking up the roads and preventing
them going to work and
if you could just listen to what
this reasonable person says then we
might be a bit more sympathetic
but firstly let's
not lose context right
we're facing the breakdown of everything
that supports civilized life on earth
right that is a fact the ipcc is saying
it everyone agrees right so
that is a pretty enormous issue if you
might say injustice for people to be
taking action against and uh it said you
know that citizens are the conscience
keepers of a democratic society now
within european church of human rights
within the uh laws in this country we
have a right to do disruptive protest
and the policing bill is going to clash
with our rights as citizens with our
human rights i don't know what the
government are planning to write into
the new bill of uk rights but the point
is we have a right to do this kind of
disruption and people should be asking
themselves what on earth is it that's so
bad that causes these doctors lawyers
teachers to be doing this extraordinary
work putting themselves at risk risking
losing their careers risking problems
that might cause with their work with
their family and all kinds of other
issues with travel you know having a
criminal record what is it that's making
so many people do that and actually the
the thing that's making people do that
is fearing for the future of civilized
life is that not you know i don't i just
i can't understand why this is such a
like difficult thing for people to get
their heads around if we make a rational
insane response to this crisis and start
to deal with it everybody will get on
board and start doing the hard work of
making things better again do you know
what i mean but you can't do that
without a massive shift and at the
moment politicians are blocking action
that the public want the public
resounding we want climate action fast
well we're coming to a point where
somebody's got to make a decision about
something um we'll go to a break and
after that um i'm going to ask you both
to
respond to what you've heard and see if
there is actually any prospect for
common ground between the two of you and
by the way i will give my view stay with
us
[Music]
this is common ground i'm joined by
claire farrell the co-founder of
extinction rebellion and zion lights
founder of the climate campaign group
emergency reactor
we've been talking about whether climate
protesters have got it wrong we're
coming to the end of our program now so
i'm going to give each of you a minute
to
tell me what you feel you've learned
from our conversation and if anything
you've heard has actually changed your
mind about the other view um
i actually think claire and i do agree
on a lot of things and even the point
that she made about you know why don't
people care i keep doing things they're
not listening i keep
ringing the alarm they're not responding
i you know i think quite a lot of us
feel like that
for me it's just led me to a different
path because i've said okay well maybe i
should try something different because i
keep doing these things
and
they're not making a difference whereas
what i feel i'm doing now it might not
get as much media attention but it's
engaging people on quite a basic level
talking about reception talking about
solutions that feels to me much more
powerful and you know
change-bringing than anything i've done
including gluing myself to things and
shutting down banks or investing in
fossil fuels and all the many many
things that i've done over the years
what i would say as well is that it
seems to me that it it's become very rad
it's become a very normal thing now to
to glue onto something or sit in a in a
road it used to be very radical idea i
think now the radical idea that i would
push is engage with the democracy that
we have engage with the politicians hold
the line and try and make things better
not just in in things like the policing
but all of the things that we've
mentioned where our rights are being
eroded because all of that is relevant
to climate action and the way that
populations are or not controlled um
through the changes that we're going to
face
claire
um
[Music]
yeah well i think me and do agree on
quite a lot of things especially around
climate and uh the rapidity of which
things need to happen um you know the
fact that we've sort of normalized civil
disobedience we've had these thousands
of scientists recently going out and
taking a restaurable action the same
thing goes for health care workers the
same thing you're hearing from antonio
guterres the secretary general of the un
saying the true radicals are the
governments that are still extracting
fossil fuels and expanding that industry
the true radicals are the industry
players who are trying to make sure that
fossil fuels don't stay in the ground
and that we continue pulling those out i
mean i i feel like
the growth of the movement does show
that you know with new movements like
just stop oil lots of youth-led
movements there's loads of direct action
that's going on around the world there's
people in australia in canada all over
europe these groups are popping up that
are using more uh disruptive tactics
where people are willing to take more
personal risk you know i do think that
we're still some way away from a social
tipping point where acting on climate
very very quickly becomes uh an
inevitability rather than something that
people are striving for but we don't
know where those social tipping points
are i still think that we're worth
carrying on trying to find them because
i don't think that it's impossible to
meet that but we need a bigger movement
okay well
this has been incredibly illuminating
for me i mean look
obviously there's common ground you both
agree on the urgency of the cause you
both agree about scale
and i should
full disclosure say that of course
before the dawn of time as a young
activist i
engaged in some
activities anti-apartheid and so on that
did get me carted away by the cops and
you both agree that actually there's a
place for that
where i think you
haven't persuaded each other is really
about the public and to what extent they
are ready to listen you think that they
still need a bit more prodding you think
that there may be better and easier ways
of getting them to listen so
i think we've got 80 of the way there
but the 20 percent
which is about human nature i guess is
still out there but quite a lot of
common ground tonight thank you both
very much
that's it from us see you again next
week
[Music]
you